oh look there's me yeah
that's awesome
you worked on episodes one and two of
the prequels and the matrix sequels
yeah hold on wait this is this is
practical the arena set itself yeah is
practical what
will
so i want to get your opinion on star
wars and star trek oh this is my
favorite subject
hey welcome back to another episode of
visual wait no special effects artist
react that's right we have a very
special guest today adam savage is on
the couch with us we have been looking
forward to this all year i'm so glad you
were able to make it thanks for having
me we get a lot of requests for for
guests to be on on the couch with us and
i'm pretty sure you are literally at the
top wow of of the list i mean people are
asking for jackie chan sure sir jackie
chan's on there
but that's almost another cat that's a
different category no it's apples and
oranges wait that's nico he's at the
hospital right now
dude i'm i wish you had a better work
ethic really honestly
hopefully some other time you'll come
back and join us
[Laughter]
how intense was that all right
i'm picturing his wife just behind the
camera
adam a lot of people know you from
mythbusters of course but you have a
rich history and experience building
things for movies so i would love to
hear some of your insights about the
special craftsmanship that makes movies
that we love possible awesome i love
this subject
you worked on episodes one and two of
the prequels you're correct back when
everything like when we thought they
were going to be great
i wasn't going to say that
look i've looked back on those prequels
very very fondly after all the new
movies
fair point tough but fair so i came in
late in production on episode one okay
look i saw star wars when it came out i
was 10 years old and it changed my life
and so i had been i'd work in special
effects and commercials and theater for
a decade a decade and a half before i
decided it's time to go up to ilm i got
to be able to leverage this together
yeah and so i ended up calling the the
manager of the model shop mark anderson
about once a week for several months i
mean i was cheeky but i also knew that
like i knew at that point in my career i
was qualified and mark eventually
brought me in and i got to spend the
last six months of episode one's
production so i only worked on newt and
roone's shuttle and a few other small
models larry tan had done most of the
the fabrication and i came in to do the
detailing with him and then he moved on
to another gig and at that point doug
chang trusted me enough so i got to
dress the bottom paint the whole model
dress the inside of the loading bay and
then put in the lighting and wire up all
the lighting and then rig it on set
while marty rosenberg shot it it was
like it was like an absolute bucket list
set of operations for this one spaceship
and this is the last movie episode one
it's the last
lucasville movie in which all the ships
are practical all the ships were almost
all the ships at least there were
practical models of every ship i mean i
remember spending a weekend covering the
queen ship with mylar the chrome queen
ship yeah covering an eight-foot
fiberglass model the queen ship with
mylar which we had to like push and
stretch to get it to move between every
panel line to have perfect stretches of
it the irony being that like that's easy
to do in cgs all three of the prequels
are absolutely beautiful
i mean if anything my issues with them
visually are that episode episode one is
almost too busy like they had all the
toys and they put them in every frame
and it was episode two where every shot
started to feel like an actual ralph
mcqueary painting
lucas since the beginning days has
relied on incredible visual artists like
ralph mcqueary and now doug chang to
visualize so much of this world not just
piecemeal but cohesively and ralph
mcqueary helped george sell the film
with an incredible set of paintings and
there's a there is a depth and a
veracity to those paintings and special
effects took a long time to catch up to
the majesty of those paintings in my
opinion but by episode two they were
like every single shot looked exactly
like an actual ralph mcqueary painting
he he developed this whole aesthetic for
the whole style of star wars very just
like a grungy style of ships and whatnot
there's so many parts to that lineage
grant mccune did the earliest prototype
models he did some beautiful work ralph
mcqueary's drawings show these ships as
used and worn out and then i've had long
talks with lauren peterson who's worked
on since star wars and he talked about
that they called it boilerplate that
basically every griebly has a purpose
and if the model maker has an
understanding of what that purpose is
it's going to sell okay and so that just
like that was my earliest understanding
that everyone below the director is also
telling stories i built the mat the
building into poker city that uh obi-wan
and django have their fight on in
episode two oh yeah so the whole
building behind them is actually also a
practical model that i built
so i see all of these details i labored
over and it's like i'm putting three
things together on the side of the
topoka city master building and i'm like
these are cooling vents and that's why
this one's missing because something hit
it and now there's a rust streak and
like i have a narrative in my head and
it doesn't work unless i do i love that
mark sigel and i built the first arena
for episode two we built the first model
of the arena so george could see it in
3d and we built a foam core model i
think was about three feet wide and in
sections so that george can go okay
great we're going to put a thing over
here and maybe we need a better entrance
of you know it's to have that discussion
be in 3d space they they made my cats
you built a like a prototype there yeah
but then the actual final arena was also
like a big it was a huge set it was
about eight six eight feet in diameter
yeah hold on the this is wait this is
this is practical the arena set itself
yeah is practical i i'm just trying to
take that in it's about eight feet in
diameter i think eight feet in diameter
they're that's the miniature behind them
like whenever you see the arena in the
distance that's shot practically on a
motion control stage getting shots to
the arena to use as background set
extensions oh no kidding yeah so i've
spent i mean those were those were rough
shoots because you're shown a rough cg
breakdown of what the action is going to
be and frequently you'll see that detail
show up on the right that might be like
marty rosenberg one of the main
cameramen for the motion control stuff
being like okay for this pull out i want
something in the foreground so could
someone run to the model shop and make
me some rocks or go grab some rocks from
the beggar canyon set and let's stick
them on a c-stand up close to the camera
so when the camera pulls out we get this
four grounds of stuff that's amazing but
then you still get that unified lighting
so it looks like it's part of the scene
yeah absolutely i will tell you i've
been on a motion control stage with
marty rosenberg shooting when the
camera's moving and we're watching the
camera and he's like that's that spot
looks too blank and we'll go in
while the camera's set up they'll put a
tarp over it and we'll airbrush extra
panels for that one shot oh absolutely
we're sculpting these shots piece by
piece frame by frame because on the
droid factory man i ran back to the
model shop like three or four times to
build whole models in a matter of couple
of hours to get them into the set months
and months and months just setting up
different conveyor belts for different
shots and adding little details in frame
so i want to get your opinion on sort of
like the aesthetics between star wars
and star trek oh this is my favorite
subject
because it's like
you know they seem kind of similar they
share four letter words and uh
they're not at all completely different
i remember a day i'm sitting there and
my mentor mitch romanowski who ran the
shop and fond davis who runs funko here
right we're all
working across the table from each other
and mitch was working on a star trek
model and fawn and i were working on
star wars models and mitch was like
why isn't this detail working here and
fawn and i we're younger than mitch by
about 10 or 12 years so we're much more
invested
in the difference between star trek and
star wars than mitch and so we
engendered a day-long conversation and
the thing is is that star trek is a
utopia yes yes star trek is utopian
they're literally opposites yeah and so
while the ships have
details and they utilize lots of the
same modeling techniques on star trek
what you'll see is physical details that
are bilaterally symmetrical which
is often in star wars but not truly
bilaterally symmetrical there'll be like
five things in a row there's never five
details in a row that are all the same
on a star wars ship yeah there's always
three and then there's a blank spot
where there's a rust streak and then
there's a different yeah right because
the the narrative in star wars is we're
still working on these things we're
trying to make them work we don't have
enough resources everybody's fighting
over the resources that's kind of the
inherent aesthetic of all of these ships
yeah the star trek ships like you can't
have a piece missing unless you're
dealing with an alien race in which
there's a scarcity model yeah i mean
everyone has a replicator you can have
anything you want you hit the button on
the replicator anything you want comes
out one of the best techniques in star
trek ships is what's called specular
highlighting so what you're seeing there
on the side of that ship is a final
painting pass of matte semi-gloss and
gloss uh friskets laser-cut friskets of
paneling that the painters after they've
done all the penalty till after they've
done all the weathering they then the
laser cutters would cut them these vinyl
friskets of just random patterns and
they would lay them on and do a
semi-gloss and pull it out
lay them on into a gloss and
just the overlapping of that adds tons
more detail and then they do a final
pass with pencils if you look really up
close at the five footer that's here in
la you'll see tons of pencil work on it
the star trek ships benefit from
specular highlighting much more because
they have much less physical detailing
they tend to have wider swaths of flat
broken by windows but still
topographically
pretty uniform so you have to break that
up with painting otherwise it there's no
scale to it and it's all about the scale
everything we're talking about is about
adding scale this thing is the size of
like hundreds of empire state buildings
glued together right like
it's still even hard for us to conceive
how big the star trek ships are like i
guess that's the thing too even like you
know we're sitting here we try and make
like a 3d model and it's the weirdest
thing ever you have this huge thing hit
render and if it's totally smooth
like it it looks fake you know what i'm
saying look at the containers falling
off the container ship in perfect storm
there's a container ship that's entirely
cg and it's beautiful but
everything is flat
and there's not enough there's not
enough physical detail breaking up the
scale of the containers and that's just
early cg that's like that's also early
cg modelers not having the same
institutional knowledge about selling
scale
oh hello there it's ren from the future
if you're enjoying this episode adam's
got a lot more cool stuff to say on the
website quarterdigital.com because we've
got extended editions of these episodes
dropping every single saturday
porterdigital.com sign up now get a
two-week trial and get everything that
we put out including a 15 off all of our
merchandise access to all of our
exclusive shows like crew cuts son of a
dungeon functional filmmaking it's great
and the future is looking bright i
highly recommend getting a subscription
also it's available on ios and android
get the apps they're available in the
app getting places
so you worked on the matrix sequels i
did that i mean
i feel like the matrix sequels they get
a bit of a bad rap but like i was a fan
of them when they came out and i i still
think there are a lot of aspects from
those movies that really really work now
you did a lot of the model work from
reloaded and
revolutions yeah they were shot
simultaneously oh that's right so we did
the effects also simultaneously out on
treasure island manix the effects
company built a huge sound stage where
they had the zion party yeah that that
that was an 11 000 square foot room wow
that in world war ii was filled with uh
mustangs
the airplanes yeah then we set up a huge
motion control stage for the dock so
when they come into the dock yes a good
portion of that
set is practical so that whole set there
that all of that the columner up to the
crane with the with all the moving gears
all that was practical so owen patterson
is a production designer of matrix and
like he is one of my all-time heroes and
i got to work in an office with him for
a year and it was great just below the
crane you see what looks like a mesh
frame above that you see the mesh frame
that's an escapement inside of which are
the gears for the elevator that brings
you up to the dock and so i did this
whole gear arrangement and so like three
days later i come oh and look at this
and i turn it and all these things turn
and he goes stop stop
i'm like what he's like don't
show the wachowskis that it moves
they will want it to move in shot and
that'll ruin our lives oh my god just
like glue it glue it down
[Laughter]
no no no no we don't have time or money
to do that
see you're making an assumption that
when you build it to be destroyed being
destroyed is the end of your mission
building something to be destroyed is
its own science and art and you put
structure in it you use aluminum foil
you use breakaway plasters foam that you
spray painted silver so silver chunks
are flying out of it when it blows up
you're literally attempting to build
something that looks great at two
hundred and fifty frames per second when
they would have to shoot it so slow-mo
for something of that size to fall at
the correct speed exactly so you don't
not only don't you mind it blowing up
blowing you making four in order so that
you can blow up and maybe hopefully the
last one doesn't get blown up
i know for uh the rocketeer um john
goodson built the blimp for the
rocketeer and when they were doing the
blimp explosion he kept on saying you
should be paying me to make two blimps
and they're like we don't have the money
and he's like you should be paying me to
make two blimps it's only a little bit
more expensive to make two and they
messed up the first shot of the blimp
explosion and they had to build a second
one and now that he wasn't able to make
him in parallel it cost more yeah it was
a worse problem not enough money to do
it right but plenty of money to do it
twice
so back to the crane though obviously
the destruction was planned but it also
looks like even the way it falls was
planned and specifically like the
wachowskis are like okay we want it to
hit here and crush there and then tumble
down so it's not just like you push it
off a stalk like they have a whole
narrative of how they want this fall to
look and effects
has to make it work so you see some
cables on it those are all about
lowering it at
at speed correctly for camera sure okay
so there's a shot towards the end of
revolutions where you know zion is about
to be overwhelmed by the sentinels and
they're coming to the rescue you know
morpheus is in tow in the passenger seat
and the kids got to come and open the
door he's the last hope of humanity
literally here
and then the ship comes blasting through
the doors
that was a practical shot involving a 15
foot long fiberglass mjolnir shaped buck
i always want to call them mjolnir
because that's what we called it on set
oh really okay yeah it was officially
the mjolnir until they were close to
release dang okay and now everyone knows
milner is thor's hammer but back then
that was a deep cut that was like the
nerdiest that was the prime nerd drop
when i laid that one down when someone
said what's thor's hammer and you went
mjolnir and everyone was like
maybe an idiot
and the doors were built out of lead
sheet and balsa so that they would tear
apart correctly in scale when they got
hit at 40 miles an hour
by this cable cold
so what i'm hearing in my head watching
this is fire in the hole because we
heard fire in the hole for months
because they just were testing
explosives or doing shots and every
single time you did somebody had to yell
fire in the hole okay that looks really
good yeah
so again realize that they're timing a
pyrotechnic effect to blow flames out of
the door enough that you see them but
not so much that they wash out the shot
and then you start to think about how to
expose for that crap and like the
coordination between departments gets
really high i noticed actually they even
have uh like the some some different
chemicals going on with the the flame
effects to get the the blue
uh because i i noticed that in the final
shot too it's like you get
the the blue fire that's coming out of
it yeah and i know that you obviously
can like tint that sometimes but it
seems like they're
they've actually achieved it there
different special sauces yeah
delicious
oh look there's me showing up in behind
the scenes
right there that's awesome
that was totally on the right
really yeah there he is
that's so funny
this is real memory lane for me yeah i'm
sure this is just like a nostalgia trip
where you're right
my goodness
adam thank you so much for coming here
today yeah like i
i knew i was gonna have fun i didn't
know i was gonna have this much fun so i
really appreciate it i mean yeah same
same it was a bit of a bit of a wrench
thrown in the gears with niko having a
baby this morning but like surprised and
that's that's the reveal
yeah
so my only question after all of this
talking is when can i come back
[Laughter]
i would love to come back we should
figure out some other things to talk
about because this is this is my whole
life is this discussion you you have a
whole youtube channel that i've been a
fan of for years
uh i did fame in reverse i started as a
television star then i became a youtuber
i'm just trying a different model yeah
so check out tested links in the
description it's a very fun youtube
channel i love the sort of like one day
builds that you have or like i'm gonna
make a thing we're just gonna do it all
day there's so much so much cool stuff
on there go check it out right now